and let me welcome to the show joseph
porrell european union representative on
foreign policy uh let's talk about oil
and gas first of all and those sanctions
which russia has learned to live with
over the past years even before this
invasion we've also seen russia's ruble
come back despite
the sanctions um but as far as oil and
gas goes
isn't it the case that eu countries are
still financing russia's war by refusing
to cut themselves off from russia all
together
look
we will be cutting the
russian gas
as soon as possible but we are not going
to cut overnight because it's impossible
due to the high dependency of
some member states
now we have approved a plan in order to
reduce this dependency
and in a very short time it was 40
before the war
it's now 20 of our imports we have
divided by two
in a couple of months
but nobody can ask the european
economies
to cut uppercut overnight the gas
supplies you said the rubble is very
high this is a mechanic effect
this is a mechanic effect if
russia cannot import because we cut
exports to russia
and the prices of
energy is
increasing everywhere
certainly
it's an economy with a
external surplus and the level goes up
but the rebels is no longer convertible
currency
so
it's not very useful to have a very high
rate your currency is not convertible
no the sanctions are hitting very hard
russian economy
they can cite several examples car
manufacturing for example
97
almost
100 of the car production in russia has
stopped
50 of the technological appliances
russia is heavily depending on
technological imports from europe
seventy percent of the
civilian fleet or russian airplanes
come from europe come from outside
russia
can can i embarrass that because that
doesn't change the fact that oil and gas
are still russia's cash cow and energy
prices are surging russia is making a
huge amount of money which means it can
afford
this war
we've known about this war for
half a year almost now
we've also known about the climate
crisis for years and yet we're still
clinging to dirty fuels instead of
renewables
enough not to interrupt me please huh
would be you've got enough to lend me
okay we've only got five minutes but
we've got another two minutes left i'll
let you go
okay look i told you yes certainly we
continue paying for our gas have you
looked at the graph of the price of oil
the price of oil started growing before
the war
and after our sanctions the price of all
has been decreasing what do you mean
that we continue paying for the gas we
buy yes certainly we continue paying for
the gas we buy
but we have reduced to half the amount
of our imports
so yes we cannot do miracles the war
machine is going to be
not only working with money he's working
with technology have a look at the
at the carcass of a destroyed russian
tank and you will see how many
western companies electronic companies
is inside there
they will longer no longer have it they
can have the money but they cannot buy
it
so they will not be able to build
another tank like this
so don't look just at the money because
the money
doesn't buy technology if the supplies
of technology don't sell it
the russian economy is decreasing by 10
of the gmp
it's going to suffer the bigger
recession of the last year since the end
of the world war since the end of the
soviet union
and yes you continue saying yes but you
continue paying for the gas as we
continue paying for the guys do you
think the russians will provide those
cash for free
but important to reduce this dependency
and we are reducing it very quickly from
40 to 20 in a couple of months
what what about something like
introducing tariffs on that russian oil
or gas i mean for years germany has
benefited from cheap gas from russia
keeping its economy competitive
yes this is something that has been
considered some economist has been
proposing the idea of putting tariffs or
caps
but we decided to go for a much stronger
decision
stop buying stop buying oil from the
from now till the end of the year and
now we are in the process of stock stop
buying gas
maybe the idea of a tariff or a
gap enterprise could have been
good to consider
from the beginning of the war but it was
not unanimity in order to implement this
kind of measures
but
what we are doing is maybe more
important that putting a tariff just
forbidden to import
are there any other ways that the eu can
put real pressure on russia to stop this
war in ukraine
do you think that the disagreement on
the wheat to be exported from ukraine
has nothing to do with the pressure that
the international community and
europeans for putting in russia in order
to allow them to export
the grain from ukraine
you know what we can do against russia
is to try to explain things the way they
are
today in africa for example we need to
do a lot of explanations in order to
make african people understand that we
are not forbidden the export of food
no grain
neither fertilizes from russia
because these are out of our sanctions
we have to continue putting pressure on
all economic sectors frozen the assets
of the oligarchs frozen the assets of
the russian economy whatever they are
this is what we can do
and stop buying gas as soon as possible
you are right on saturday we continue
paying but this is going to be decreased
quickly
and more important than that is to cut
the links of the russian economy with
the rest of the world
a modern economy cannot be work if the
link with the rest of the big economic
power big technological powers like u.s
canada uk and europe
are caught
this is something that will damage about
the russian economy not tomorrow the war
will continue unhappily it will continue
but the russian economy will suffer a
lot and putin will have to choose
between having guns or having butter for
their people well i know that he doesn't
care a lot about their people
well let's hope we do find an end to
this war sooner rather than later joseph
thank you very much for your time and
for debating those issues eu
representative on foreign policy
pleasure to have you on the show